[Laughter]
i brought some shot glass i hear you
don't drink uh you don't drink beer
i drink not not usually i like a cider
every now and then i'm not i'm a wine
girl
you're from texas and you don't drink i
know and here's the thing doesn't this
personality
scream beer i exude like she likes i
never thought that when i first saw you
i didn't go like honey the beer girls
then you didn't see me properly
my friends are more shocked than anyone
have you ever done a beer commercial
no i wouldn't no would you do a beer
commercial how much am i being paid
a lot i can drink beer for money all
right this is a sparkling white okay
sparkling wine
sparkling white uh it's from spain
lovely
love espana yep
so cold i don't know what you're talking
about yeah we'll move on to the red in a
bit okay
okay i like it get the first one we
should have had like a charcuterie board
or something it's gonna be a whole like
this is interesting ellen never does
this
no we both love wine and food you are if
we do it and wine
probably too much is there too much i
don't know
it's not like i would do it while i was
being interviewed
not during the day before not in front
of a group of people
no why would i do that i have no i don't
have a problem
you're fine i'm fine everyone's fine um
i need to ask you though welcome back to
everyone's fine
with kelly clarkson that's my new book
um
i need to ask you about this video joel
can you joe can you roll this footage
what's happening here all right so that
uh
that's thanksgiving that's a turkey
actually is that stuffing in the turkey
wait that's okay
this is all right so uh there's a
there's a butcher shop here called
mccall's meeting fish and this amazing
butcher named megan decided she would
take an entire turkey
before it was cooked take all the meat
off and the skin
wrap it all back in the skin with the
stuffing
and you put that in the oven and you
roast it for two and a half hours and it
comes out
looking like you cooked an alien but it
is here's the thing
it looks like something i want to eat
right now so i'm into it uh did you
bring one did you see how juicy that all
right
very moist it was exactly how it was i
got two of them uh we have 20 or 30
people over for thanksgiving oh my gosh
she's a big family
yeah no and they they just like free
stuff and so
they all come down from seattle and they
stay with us 10 like 11 people stay in
the house and uh i
cook and so does my wife and and then we
we have this huge dinner and then i
resent my family for six months
all right something else i know um that
you love is your dog
your dog is always on instagram is it a
bean bag i don't have any dogs
you have a dog yeah exactly i have three
dogs yeah so a bean bag the dog well you
have three dogs why do you only
i don't i only see the one bean bag is
the yeah that's
he's he's crazy i like honestly oh and
he's attacking me
[Applause]
that's a normal morning uh he's
a very excitable um french bulldog if
you could
there's no audio there which is really
taking away from it
we make a lot of silent films as you can
see uh
and uh he he's one of those morning
kisses tore my shirt off earlier so
uh yeah he's insane and we have these
two other dogs that
get no press uh because they're well
there he is again
that's how oh they're more that's cowboy
and harry and they're just
miserable because as all the time the
and that there he is
maniac no but you don't have any cats
though right
no i love cats i'm allergic my wife is
horribly alone
but uh after because the beanbag and
cowboy have fur not hair
yeah having been around them for so long
she figured out that she basically lost
her
uh allergy to cats and so now i'm like
we have switched floodgates
uh i need to get some cats fine bring
out the cats
oh that is not what i mean
damn it oh my god
oh guys these are actual cats they're
actually little kittens this is y'all
all these kittens
are brothers and sisters from the same
litter the black and white ones are
named
spatzle bucatini and zit ziti
and the orange ones are orzo ravioli
and bigelow somebody likes pasta right
holy sorry
and those are all different types of
sushi
they're going to hang out with us though
for a bit and by the end of the show
maybe joel will adopt one
yeah or he might do the smart thing and
wait for his wife's okay
i'm going to adopt two and then i'll get
a divorce because my wife will be like
what is going on so
if anyone else wants to adopt these
kittens you can visit them at paul works
adoption center and come here
they're mine they're my cats i mean
these kittens are famous
as well okay a super girl the dog okay
they've been on tv you're gonna look at
their faces
my husband is so nervous right now yeah
i don't even care that i'm allergic i'll
take a pill or something or a shot
you gotta push that cat across the table
like you're putting in a bet
playing tennis i'll raise you two cats
how much do you like cuddles right
speaking of work though um you're super
talented
you've got two films at the tribeca film
festival right now right yeah
one's called i found a kitty and you
know what it's called
hey look a squirrel yeah uh
yes i do i'm you know because it's at a
film festival so you'll all see it
uh and won't be distracted at all
by by the cat olympics happening on
let's just you know what let's just let
them go enjoy
enjoy yourselves just go wait they can't
hurt themselves right if they come off
of the
don't all cats land on your feet or some
or their feet okay
no no no what are you talking about no
i've heard this if a cat like falls or
something they they so the cat falls
they land on their feet oh my god it's
on the back i'm a mom
i'm a mom you gotta get it you gotta get
it you gotta get it gonna be fine it's
gonna
this is how they learn this is how they
learn
oh i've gotta get you i've gotta give
you anyway i see you guys are very
excited about my films
[Applause]
this is all right look i mean
have you ever seen they're set up
they're set up this guy better fall in
line
all right go over there oh you're
crawling you are a crawler
oh you're going all the way around so
about your films
that guy you're crazy i don't want you
to die man
okay so about your films i don't know
becky and happily yes becky is made by
uh it's a
great uh it's me and a wonderful actress
named lulu wilson and kevin james
uh it is it is definitely not a comedy
and then uh the other one's called
happily uh directed by a guy named
ben david grobinski and it's been a
wonderful actor
named uh carrie boucher and steven root
who
you've seen on barry in a thousand other
things radio
and uh but no one's listened to a thing
i've said it doesn't matter
let's get all the cats let's just move
on to the red and let's see what happens
it's fine it's fine it's fine take a sip
oh wait that's mine that's that's yeah
yeah yeah yeah just kidding it's just
like natural
that's fine that's fine okay so that
that will come out yeah that's in april
and i know you'll all go to the film
festival you're gonna love it
all right it's fine it's fine it's a cat
wait okay wait
joel so car sharks car sharks is back
look um do you like being a game host is
it fun what is a game host
a game you're hosting a game i think
it's in the definition isn't the name
i think it's game show
the game show host game show we give
away cats
and uh please don't die it's gonna go
great uh
yeah you can win look yes it's you can
win a lot of money i can totally get you
on the show yeah okay uh
but if you think about it kelly nobody
has listened to a thing we have said
in the last few minutes well be sure to
catch all the things
you're really excited about watch car
sharks this summer on
abc who cares we're having fun
also he has the film's becky and happily
coming out but we'll be right back with
empire's grace virus also known as the
villainous
ex-wife of lucious lions stay with us
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel
please don't make me keep going